welcome to this video will play the test
waiking and it's a cool name somehow the
test waiking FM row on socket ok let's
do some kind of always playing the
double fianchetto my own openings ok bit
surprised that allow t5 usually any kind
of hope sorry hope for an opening
advantage is gone once you allow 'if
I've yeah okay here black is just very
comfortable soma Roxy with reverse
colors go ok so d4 I probably will go
before he's angling for before I guess
okay maybe just trade this trade this
Bishop shouldn't be bad okay so he
managed to get in before remarkably
enough and so let's shut down that
Bishop it takes you 5 i'm going to get
that back sooner or later no interesting
who my takes hmm
he's got to unprotected pieces on the be
found assesses okay if he takes it queen
be several miss an interesting idea no
he doesn't I never understand moves that
that's not good okay if I just cover
let's say with this
I mean ever pretty big space advantage
he cannot just sit there with this crap
Bishop and be too and though the both
both nights being bad or is that really
what he wants to sit down he just want
this wants to sit down in his big bad
position interesting okay threatening
would be eight now and those pieces will
fall apart B 3 and B 2 and I'm not quite
sure why he wanted to open the B file in
general
maybe you can play a form somehow a4p a
Droog a three but I hat doesn't look
good
so a 4 or not it looks like a good move
now push that night back now those
pieces look quite funny ok I definitely
want to get an f5 again in f5 and f4
then the game is effectively over and
she is unable to move those pieces ever
f5 and f4 can almost proved f5 in this
position
let's check this F for I have bishop age
six things yeah
so h5 Bishop h6 next oh is it coming
with Ruby 5 stuff like that mmm I don't
know should I play hoop be 81 I don't
think don't think it is a problem maybe
I should have played more on the
queenside rupees salad it can be
slightly slightly tricky
so be more concerned about be seven but
it's all that's also not not totally
easy
I mean that space advanced it should be
overwhelming but well so takes on g3
takes on f3 it's not not decisive as bad
as it looks
I don't want to trade stuff maybe I can
do this and go night is six get more and
get more firepower okay okay let's stick
just recaptures time for H for a move h4
looks very brutal let's do that now that
that should have been much much clearer
that game
much clearer neither three maybe now the
map totally misplayed that I completely
miss played that game at position check
here it's not even that clear
ja what rubbish what did I do to this
position air and was completely winning
for for black it was so utterly winning
amazing Jack ha I hate it when it's like
a complete win and you don't look
anymore and stuff here check and his his
chat line I'm just coming first with
this 22 pieces there oh my god and this
is this is epic this is just a
completely lost position from while you
can look at this ridiculous pieces
unbelievable ah ok now it was it was
good for quite a long time here yeah
maybe now the engine is of course right
it wants to do this and this makes an
awful lot of sense just put a night on
v3 and completely stop the queenside
that that anything happens on the
queenside and then you can you can just
yeah put all the pieces on the Kings
Island checkmate wide ok the way I
played it probably also wins I mean this
is like overwhelming at this G for
business but it's it was it was possible
to screw it up quite obviously right in
five again was winning but this is also
just win but I managed to screw it up
really did ng5 was highly irritating and
it is good for why damn amazing I was
thinking let rook f2 always should be
something but it simply isn't it simply
isn't can still get a very good position
with with
normal moves just continue with their
tech I mean what kind of stuff is that
but it's far too complicated it's hard
to complicate it shouldn't shouldn't be
like that if you if you look at this
this is this position which is just it's
just crazy he never did anything to
prevent that you just played the most
passive moves ever dumb yeah yeah this
is ok I played that all right I just
should go here that that's it's just
easier put something on b3 I mean he has
to play something weird to even not
loose material him something like this
this this and now I can just yeah just
do normal attacking and yes this is just
impossible let's get get here and so on
I don't know it was like a minute out of
the clock I think I relax too much I
relax too much like okay this wins with
every move and whatever and so yeah this
is a typical danger that you that you
can easily afford fall into we are you
you think of me your opponent really
plays a terrible game and you think okay
he's never going to you can play
anything now in and it's not the case
sometimes they they play a terribly and
then well it continues then you continue
then you continue then you don't find
the find a final blow and then somehow
yeah somehow they escape and find stuff
I mean it's not difficult but to play
stuff like g5 and queen age 5 comes I
cannot move the bishop check check check
check check it was funny that I check or
even there but it doesn't matter
okay thanks for watching